اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام واحييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
العسكريين البريطانيين اهدافا عسكريه
مشروعه لدعم بلادهم لاوكرانيا
الجيش السوداني يعلق مشاركته في مباحثات
جده واستمرار الاشتباكات مع الدعم السريع
رقم الهدنه
المطلق للصرب
اباطره الذكاء الاصطناعي يحذرون من مخاطره
قد يهدد البشريه جمعا باسلحه محرمه دوليا
اذا مشاهدينا اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه تدمير
اخر سفينه حربيه اوكرانيه وذلك في ميناء
اوديسا المتحدث باسمي الوزاره ايغور
كوناشينكو قال ان معارك عنيفه تجريب القرب
من بلدتي على محور دونيسكا ودونيسكو عذرا
مشيرا الى احباط انشطه ثلاث مجموعات
استطلاع تخريبيه اوكرانيه على محور
كوبيانسك وتدمير مستودعات ذخيره تابعه
للقوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه هاركيف
الدفاع الروسيه اضافت ان انظمه الدفاع
الجوي اسقطت المزيد من صواريخ هيمرز وستور
ومباشره معنا من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعمي اهلا بك كاتيا اخر التطورات
الميدانيه تفضلي
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل اليوم كانت الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت عن انها قامت بصد هجمات
اوكرانيه باستخدام صواريخ شادو وصواريخ
ايضا اسقاط نحو 12 صاروخا من طراز هايمرز
ايضا واسقاط نحو ايضا 15 مسيره في مناطق
في منطقه دونيس بالاضافه لذلك ميسون
الهجمات لا تزال مستمره على الاراضي
الروسيه من الجانب الاوكراني سواء كانت
باستخدام المسيرات او باستخدام ايضا
الصواريخ هناك كان اصابه في منطقه كورس
كريش لشخصين نتيجه القصف الاوكراني كما
تحدثت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه طبعا الموقف
الروسي ميسون حقيقه حول ادانه هذا القصف
الذي يستهدف بشكل مستمر
يستمر القصف الذي يستهدف بشكل مستمر
الاراضي الروسيه تحدث عنه الكريم الذي
طبعا ادان عدم وجود موقف واضح للغرب
وادانا لهذه التصرفات من جانب اوكرانيا
بالحديث عن القصف او الهجوم يوم امس
بالمسيرات الذي استهدف العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو كان قد تحدث الكرملين منذ الصباح
والمتحدثه باسم الخارج الروسيه عن ان هذا
الموقف يعتبر غير كافي ودني وبالاخص في
ضوء تصريحات لندن والمانيا بانهما لا
يعتبران
القصف او استهداف كيف للاراضي الروسيه
بانه غير مشروع بالنسبه للتحقيقات التي
جرت هل لدينا تفاصيل عن كيفيه
وتحرك هذا هذه الصواريخ او المسيرات
بالاحرى بالامس لانه روسيا اعلنت ان هناك
تحقيق سيتم للتاكيد على انه كيف هي من تقف
وراء هذه العمليه
حقيقه روسيا هي قبل بدء هذا التحقيق
اعتبرت ان اوكرانيا هي من تقف وراء هذه
الاعمال وصفتها بالاعمال الارهابيه طبعا
لجنه التحقيق فتحت تحقيقا حول كيفيه وصول
هذه المسيرات الى العاصمه الروسيه نوعيتها
وان كانت تم اطلاقها طبعا
اعتمادا على نوع نوع هذه المسيرات
امكانيتها لقطع مسافات طويله يمكن تحديد
فيما اذا كان تم اطلاقها من داخل الاراضي
الروسيه او من الحدود او من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه القريبه من الحدود الروسيه
ولكن حتى الان هذه التحقيقات
بدات ولكن لم يصدر اي معلومات جديده رسميه
من الجانب طبعا لجنه التحقيق الروسيه حول
التفاصيل نحن بانتظار صدور اي بيانات
جديده حول هذا الامر ميسون وكان في
تصريحات للرئيس الروسي بانه ستتم عمليه
اعاده تقييم العمليه العسكريه بصوره عامه
اي جديد بهذا الاطار
يعني هي العمليه العسكريه ميسون مستمره
وبالاخص كما يتحدث الكرملين دائما ان هذه
الهجوم بالمسيرات تؤكد ان روسيا بدات
بالطريق صحيح ببدئها هذه العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا هي كما تقول مستمره وان طبعا
روسيا مستعده
لقصف وضرب اي اسلحه جديده تصل من الغرب
الى الى اوكرانيا وبالاخص كنا قد شهدنا
خلال الايام السابقه تسريحه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيا لها قامت ايضا
بتدمير انظمه باتريوت الامريكيه التي كانت
طبعا هي على الاراضي الاوكرانيه لذلك
روسيا هي مستمره بهذه العمليه العسكريه
حتى تحقيق جميع الاهداف كما تقول موسكو
دائما من موسكو مراسلات العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
ايضا اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بلغراود الروسيه في
ان اوكرانيا استهدفت الاقليم
269 مره طبعا خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
كانت اخر لاستهدافات ما تعرضت له منطقه
فجر هذا اليوم والتي خلفت اربع اصابات قال
بلادكوف ان القصف الاوكراني ادى كذلك الى
الحاق اضرار ببنايات سكنيه ومدرسه
ومنشاتين صناعيتين كان حاكم المقاطعه قد
تاكد سابقا ان المدفعيه الاوكرانيه لا
تبعد سوى حوالي سبعه كيلو مترات الى
الشمال من الحدود مع اوكرانيا من جهه اخرى
اعلنت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في لوغانسك
مقتله خمسه اشخاص واصابه سته عشر اخرين في
قصف اوكراني بصواريخ هيمرس
وقد قال مسؤولون روس ان طائره مسيره
اوكرانيه اشعلت حريقا بلمصفات ابيبسكي
النفط في جنوب روسيا حيث اكد حاكم منطقه
كراش ندار الروسيه بنمي كوند ان الطائره
المسيره هي السبب المحتمل في اندلاع
الحريق مضيفا ان وحدات الاطفاء اخمدته
سريعا دون وقوع اصابات هذا وتقع هذه
المصفاه في منطقه قريبه من ميناء
على البحر الاسود وبالقرب ايضا من مصفاه
اخرى تعرضت للهجوم عده مرات هذا الشهر
ومن مدينه بلغروده الروسيه مفرد العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد اخر
التطورات تفضل
مساء الخير ميسون ما زالت حكومه الاقليم
هنا في بيلجرد تقوم بارسال تحذيرات
للمواطنين في كافه المناطق الحدوديه
ابرزها يكمن طبعا في مدينتين ميسون هي
شيبكينا وجريفاروم تلك المناطق التي تنال
حصه الاسد من الضربات طبعا العربيه كان
لها تجربه اليوم بمحاوله الوصول الى التي
تعرضت لاكثر من 150 ضربه خلال الليله
الماضيه حسب روايه السلطات لكن طبعا الوضع
هناك كارثي ان صحى التعبير ميسون تحذيرات
الانذار كانت تدوي في كل مكان اصوات
الانفجارات وسقوط قذائف كنا نسمعها وكانت
تبدا يعني كانت قريبه بشكل كبير زرنا طبعا
اليوم
يعني المكان الذي خصصته حكومه الاقليم
لنقل سكان من المناطق الحدوديه نحو العمق
الروسي نوعا ما تحسبا للوضع الراهن والوضع
الحساس في لكن طبعا بعض استهداف هذا
المركز يوم الامس ومقتل شخصين واصابه
اربعه قامت سلطات الاقليم على ما يبدو
بنقل كافه اللاجئين من هذا المكان نحو
مناطق اخرى
الاقليم اليوم بدات
لتوضيح الصوره اكثر في عمليات اجلاء في
عمليات نزوح ام ماذا وعن تم الاعداد التي
نتحدث عنها
يعني عمليات الاجلاء تاتي من قبل سلطات
المدينه للشيوخ للاطفال للنساء اما عمليات
النزوح فتاتي من الرجال والشباب نحو مناطق
في الداخل الروسي لكن طبعا حسب الاحصاءات
الرسميه
ذهبت اليوم حكومه الاقليم وراحه او اطلقت
عمليه نقل الاطفال من هذه المناطق
الحدوديه نحو العمق الروسي بعيدا نحو
مدينه فارونج اول 300 طفل وصلوا الى هناك
حسب روايه السلطات تحت مسمى العطله
الصيفيه لكن كما شاهدنا اليوم على ارض
الواقع لا يمكن ميسون الوقوف هناك لمده
خمس دقائق او مراقبه الوضع تخيلي ميسون
عند وصولنا الى هناك بعد اربع او خمس
دقائق كنا نلاحظ بان المسيرات ملات المكان
يعني هناك اكثر من مسيرتين او ثلاثه على
ما يبدو حسب روايه الامن في المنطقه تقوم
هذه المسيرات باخذ الاحداثيات وتقديمها
ومن ثم تجري عمليه القصف لذلك عمليه
اجلائنا اجلاء فريق العربيه من تلك
المنطقه اليوم وهي على حدود شباكنا لن
نتمكن من الوصول الى مركز المدينه كنا فقط
على مشارف هذه المدينه كانت عبر مدراء
عسكريه ماذا عن التعزيزات على الارض
وبالمقابل عند ردود الفعل بالنسبه للناس
[موسيقى]
ميسون يعني اصبح شيء معروف للمواطن الجالس
في مدينه بيليجراد وكما نشاهد يعني مدينه
تعيش حاله طبيعيه هذا هو مركز المدينه
تسمع يوميا بين الفينه والاخرى ضربات
لانظمه الدفاع الجوي تستهدف مسيرات لكن
التعزيزات تاتي يوميا عند منتصف الليل
اصبح المواطن هنا يعرف الضربات ومن يوجهها
الكثير من الانباء تتحدث عن ان القوات
الروسيه تقوم بتوجيه ضربات عند منتصف ليله
كل يوم تقريبا لذلك نلاحظ هذا العدد
واعلان حاله الانذار في الكثير من
المقاطعات الاوكرانيه المجاوره لهذا
الاقليم الحدودي الذي يمتد رابط 400 كيلو
متر تقريبا مع الجانب الاوكراني اما بما
يخص التعزيزات على الارض ميسون فحكومه
الاقليم راحت تتحدث بان
ردود الفعل يعني المواطن في المنطقه هنا
ميسون اصبح يتحدث بشكل واضح بان الوضع
خطير جدا ومقلق خاصه مع وجود اجهزه تحذير
قديمه جدا يعني تسمع هذه الاجهزه فقط
عندما تسقط قذائف او مسيرات او عبوات
ناسفه اما فهناك قرابه ثلاثه الاف جندي تم
تدعيمهم للاقليم الطويل مزاج الشارع اكثر
للرد وبقوه عبد الجواب طويله كما يقول او
وقف الحرب
اذا استطعت ان تتلمس ردود الفعل يعني
يعني الجميع يبحث
الجميع يبحث عن وقف الحرب جميعهم يتاملون
بان المرحله القادمه قد تكون افضل لكن
خيبه امل لدى الكذب لدى كثيرين منهم من
يتحدث بان هذه الحرب مستمره لا يمكن اليوم
الاتفاق بين موسكو وكيف حول هذا الموضوع
لا يمكن السيطره على مناطق خاركه في التي
تاتي منها الضربات لذلك هو الوضع صعب كما
يرونا والطلاب ذاهبون للدراسه عن بعد كما
اجروا العام الماضي والاعمال التجاريه شبه
متوقفه في المدينه باستثناء المركز الذي
نقف فيه لذلك الوضع كما هو هي حاله الحرب
الروسيه مفرد العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي خضم حرب المسيرات بين موسكو وكيف اشار
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسيه دي مترمد
فيدف الى ان لندن تخوض في الواقع حربا غير
معلنه ضد موسكو نشر تغريده قال فيها ان
بريطانيا ومن خلال دعمها لاوكرانيا
بالسلاح والمعدات العسكريه تكون قد فتحت
باب المواجهه بينها وبين موسكو فاضافها
بالقول ان هذا يعني ان كل مسؤول بريطانيا
عسكري او مدني يمكن اعتباره هدفا عسكريا
مشروعا لروسيا
المزيد معنا من موسكو الدبلوماسي السابق
والمحلل السياسي في اهلا بك سيد دعني ابدا
بهذه التصريحات وقراءتك لها ماذا تعني
لماذا بريطانيا تحديدا
لا يفرقوا كثيرا بين موقف امريكي وبريطاني
ولكن ضمن موقف امريكي بريطاني مشترك هناك
خصوصيات ويعتبرون سياسيين ومحللين في
موسكو ان موقف بريطانيا اكثر تشددا من اي
مواقف اي دوله
اوروبيه او غربيه اخرى حتى الولايات
المتحده اسمح لسيد فتشيلاف اكثر من
الولايات المتحده العدو الرئيسي بالنسبه
روسيا
كما يعتبرون محللين انه امريكانا احيانا
يتخذون موقف اكثر اعتدالا بمقارنه مع
بريطانيا
والاشاك هذا ينعكس على تصريحات الشخصيات
الرسميه اولا وشيطان هناك يعتبرون انه
تشدد في مواقف قياده عسكريه اوكرانيه
مرتبطه مع موقف بريطاني اكثر حتى بمقارنه
وتاثير موقف امريكي طيب كيف يمكن ان نفسر
ذلك اذا ما صح بالفعل انه بريطانيا اكثر
تشددا من باقي الدول الموضوع انتقام
لاسباب معينه او انه الموضوع تاريخي
موضوع التاريخي اولا وشيء ثاني
البريطانيا لها تقاليد قديمه وعند
معرفه اوضاع سياسيه واكثر من
امريكا ولذلك دور بريطانيا في
هجمه على روسيا هو اهم حتى من دوره امريكا
وانا لا اقلل دوره الامريكيه لانه كل
الاوقات
اقتصاديه منبسطه من واشنطن ولكن عمليا
خطوات معادله لروسيا متشدده مثل ما هو
ارسال الصواريخ او قنابل مع محور مع حديدي
وهو مصنوع من يورانيوم منذ منحافظ هذا هو
دليل الواضح ان امريكان احيانا لا يقبلون
ارسال بعض الاسلحه
بريطانيا تتقدم
واول اخر رغم ان البعض سيد فيجسلاف يقولون
بانه بريطانيا لا يمكن لها ان تتحرك دون
التنسيق والدعم من الولايات المتحده بس
عندي سؤال عندما روسيا تقول انه كل مسؤول
بريطانيا او حتى مدني هو هدف شرعي بالنسبه
لروسيا نتحدث عن اي رقعه جغرافيه هنا
اولا تابعنا حاكمه
ان هذا في اثار سياسه مشتركه امريكيه
بريطانيه كما يقولون عندنا ولكن في هذه
الاثار هناك
فوائد من هو يطرح الموضوع لان هو يشجع
اكثر منه موقف متشدد اكثر
وهذا المواصفات الان يقراون في مواقف
غربيه بين فرنسا المانيا امريكا بريطانيا
ليس هناك كبده واحده ليش هناك الفكر
السياسيه واحده اما بريطانيا هي تاخذ موتو
اكثر التشدا ولا كان هناك شكوك ان
هذه الطائرات مسيره هذا ليست شغلات
رعايه الامريكيه اما برعايه البريطانيه
اكثر وبالتالي
اين تتواجد هل نحن نتحدث عن توسيع رقعه
الحرب او لا
وريق بدات تصل الى الى موسكو ايضا
اولا ان
الطائرات مسيره الذي وصلت الى نقاط معينه
في ضواحي موسكو نقاط استراتيجيه
مركز القياده
صواريخ استراتيجيه هو طبعا لا ممكن ان
يؤشر من قبل الطيرات صغيره مثل ما هو كانت
اسقطوها ضواحف ولكن اسقطوها حساسه
ويعتبرون ان هذا اشاره على انه
نفسيه الى روسيا الى قياده روسيه سياسيه
وعسكريه وبالتالي
الوقت الاهداف مشروعه اين
باختصار لو سمحت اهداف مشروع انه هذا ليست
على اراضي
الاراضي البريطانيه طبعا هذا ليست كلمه
سليمه وصحيحه اما اهدافه مشروعه في
اوكرانيا في اوكرانيا الكثير من المراكز
يسيطرون فيها خبراء مستشرين
عسكريين امريكا بريطانيين وتابعوا روسيا
اعدت اشاره انها في علم اماكن الاقامه تلك
هؤلاء الناس
شرعي سيكون ضربه عليهم وكذلك الكثير من
الاسرى البريطانيين وصارت تبديلهم على
بعض
في مر الماضيه ولذلك هم الان
خارج تلك الاتفاقات حول احترام
الامور في الايام اللاحقه نتبعها من موسكو
الدبلوماسي السابق والمحلل السيادي
السياسي فيتش لافما توزوف شكرا جزيلا لك
ولكن بعد قليل
الادعاء الالمانيه يتهم سبعه اشخاص بجمع
اموال لصالح داعش وارسالها للتنظيم في
سوريا
اهلا بكم مجددا نكمل الخامسه من السودان
الذي لا يزال تحت وطاه صراع مسلح لا ينتهي
مراسل العربيه افدى بتجدد القصف المدفعي
في شمال ام درمان بالخرطوم وعلى صعيد جهود
التسويه على الاقل جيش السوداني مشاركته
في مفاوضات جده دون الانسحاب منها مراسله
العربيه افادت بان الجيش السوداني ابلغ ان
قوات الدعم السريع لم تلتزم ببنود الهدنه
وانه لا معنى للاستمرار في تمديدها في ظل
الخروج التي ترتكبها قوات الدعم السريع من
جانبه قال مصدر في الخارجيه السودانيه ان
قوات الدعم السريعه استغلت الهدنه لشن
هجمات متناسقه وساعه لادخال اسلحه وايضا
مقاتلين لمناطق عده في العاصمه وخارج
العاصمه ايضا
وقد افاد براس العربيه باغلاق كوبري
الفتحات من جهه ام درمان بالخرطوم اضافه
ان الطيران الحربي عاود التحليق في سماء
ام درمان طبعا بالتزامن مع سماعه دوي
اطلاق نار متقطع في منطقه المهندسين
طبعا مساحه المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع متوسعه في مناطق خارج العاصمه حيث
نشر الجيش السوداني مقطعا مصورا لقواته من
مدينه الابيض في ولايه شمال كردفان اكد
انه تفضل لهجوم من قوات الدعم السريعه
للمدينه كبدها ايضا خسائر فادحه
المزيد معي من القاهره المحلله السياسي
السوداني عمار عوض وايضا معي من لندن
عمران عبد الله حسن عضو المكتب الاستشاري
لقائد قوات الدعم السريعه اهلا بك سيدي
ابدا معك سيد عمران وتعليق اول على تجميد
المفاوضات من قبل الجيش تفضل
طيب السلام عليكم ورحمه الله التحيه لك
الاستاذ عمار
بخصوص التجميد طبعا انا اؤكد بعض الحاجات
الجيش اول حاجه هو تجمد عمليه التفاوض
بجده لكنه لم ينسحب من التفاوض اشيل اخر
ايضا لجنه الدعم السريع تسلمت للوساطه
احتياج على تدمير موقع الامم المتحده
بالخرطوم
والامم المتحده ادانه هذا هذا التصرف
بالتالي
هذا ادخل القوات الشعب المسلحه في احراج
والمتفاوضين في احراج ايضا هنالك خروقات
قامت بها قوات الشعب المسلحه بضرب المغاره
اليونسيف بالطيران مما دفع مندوب الجيش
للاعتذار ولكنهم على البساطه لم تقبل هذا
الاعتذار فبالتالي
لم تجد القوات الشعب المسلحه غير انها
تسحب مسيليها من التفاوض هذا هو سبب
الاساسي في عمليه الانسحاب
دعني انتقل للسيد عمار
لتعليق على ما ذكرته خاصه انه الحديث من
قبل البعض يقول انه هذا الانسحاب هو فقط
بسبب الخروقات من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
وانها محاوله ربما تكون
لتصويب مسار المفاوضات سيد عمار
نعم ليس لتطويل لكن القوات الشعب المسلحه
هي اسمها قوات الشعب المسلحه اي هي القوات
المنوط بها القوات الرسميه للمنوض بها على
الدفاع عن هي تقع تحت ضغطي مختلفه
الاتجاهات ليس كما يقول
عمران فيما يتعلق
بغصفي مكان او غيره من هذه الاسباب التي
ليس لها اي وجود قوات الدعم السريع
الخروقات التي قامت بها والتي تعتبر
خروقات كبيره تشكل احراج
للشعب السوداني والقياده الجيش المتمثله
بعسكريا
المهاجمه منطقه الاستراتيجيه وهي التي تطل
على
التي تقود الى سلاح المدرعات وصك العمله
والتي تقود من هذه الناحيه الى جسر ام
درمان عبر طريقه للغابه تم التعدي على هذا
المكان وهذا المكان كان تحت سيطره
الجيش السوداني الهجمات المنسقه على منطقه
المهندسين من المحور المتعلق بجنوب
غرب غرب المهندسين مناطق احياء ام درمان
والفتيحاب وغيره الهجومات المنسقه في
محاوله نقل الصراع الى ولايات اخرى الان
في ولايه البحر الاحمر تم التحفظ على
اسلحه تم دخولها الى مدينه بورسودان وتم
الكشف عنها دخول افراد محاوله نقل الصراع
الى اللبيض التي تشهد تحديات مستمره من
قوات الدعم السريع لو سمحت دقيقه بس لو
سمحتي هذه كلها
خروقات اصبحت خطيره جدا ولكنها ليست
بالخروقات الجديده والبعض يقول بانه الجيش
السبق هذه الخطوه بالقول بانه يستطيع ان
يرد على قوات الدعم السريع بطريقه مميته
او ضربات مميته وبالتالي كانت النيه
موجوده هذا ما يقال باختصار تفضل تعليقك
لا ليس هنالك اي حديث حول مئه مميته
بالنسبه لهذه الخروقات العسكريه تشكل ضغط
على قياده الجيش مننا نحن الشعب السوداني
نسال
عذرا هذه التصريحات يعني انا
اخذت كلماته بالتحديد عندما ذكرت هذه
النقطه انه الجيش قادر على الرد وبطريقه
انا فاهم انا ما فيك تقول ما حدا قال هذا
الكلام بطريقه
لا انا ما قلت لك ما في حد قال لا هو
الجيش السوداني دقيقه يا عزيزتي تفضل لهذا
لفائده شعبنا وللمشاهدين في العرب وفي كل
مكان البرهان تحدث على انه حتى الان لم
يستعمل القوه المميته بالتالي هو يفضل
الطريق الذي تسير عليه المحادثات لكن قلت
لك نحن نحن الشعب السوداني محمد احمد وابو
بكر وجبر الدار كلنا الشعب السوداني نسال
قياده الجيش السوداني لماذا تكسب قوات
الدعم السريع اراضي جديده في ظل الهدنه
لماذا تنتقل الصراع الى مدينه اللبيض ماذا
ينتقل الصراع الى ولايات اخرى
هذا السؤال دعنا نطرحه على السيد عمران
ليجيب القضيه بانه قوات الدعم السريع بدات
تخرج عن حدودها فيما يتعلق بالارض وايضا
الخطوط الحمى ربما الكادت موضوع على الاقل
سيد عمران
طيب شكرا لك حاجه اول حاجه بالنسبه لخطاب
البرهان طبعا الخطاب فارغ غير مسؤول لان
البرهان قال نحن الان لم ننقل الان الحرب
المميته لم لم نرجع لها بعض والان العالم
يشهد وانتم كذلك يشهدون الطيران
سريع ايضا خرقت الهدنه الدعم السريع يقال
بانها كانت تستخدم المناطق السكنيه
والمدنيين كدروع بشريه وانتشرت بين
الاحياء فالكل محقوق بهذا الاطار سيد
عمران نعلم نعم سيده الفاضل انا اعرف ذلك
جيدا ما تقولينه لكن بالمنطق نحن هذه
القوات الدعم السريع هذه اماكن تمركوزها
بعد ما جاءت الهدنه نحن ما زلنا في اماكن
تمركزنا ولم نعتدي لكن الطيران يضربنا ليل
نهار يضرب ولم يتوقف ليوم واحد من التحليق
والاستكشاف وتطلبوا من الدعم الس
ريع على نفسه فهذه يعني الكيل بالمثالين
الدعم السريع في سبيل الدفاع عن نفسه
استولى على المنطقه الاستراتيجيه الامس
بخطابه
حدد فيه شعب السوداني وانه لانه لا يخطط
لا يستطيع قتل الدعم السريع بل هو يقتل في
الشعب السوداني وهددهم بمزيد من القتل
الشيء
نعم نعم
هذا نقله النظافه السابق وكل الادله اثبتت
ذلك هو حتى بعمليه التسليح واعلن عنه
مباشره امام الملا هو قال تسليح
المتقاعد المتقاعدين الاعمار فوق السبعين
عاما الليل ليس هنالك
لكنه بطريقه اخرى يريد ان يصلح الشعب
السوداني
الدعم الاخوان والنظام السابق كونه يتحرك
على الارض باختصار سيد عمران كيف ترد على
هذه الاوعيه بالاحرى سيد عمار كيف ترد على
هذه النقاط وبالفعل الكل شاهد الطيران
الحربي يقصف عدد من المناطق ومنها مناطق
سكنيه ايضا وبالتالي الدعم السريع يقول
بانه في حاله دفاع عن النفس
لم يقصف الطيران السوداني اي مناطق سكنيه
في وجود وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وغيره لم
يسجل اي مواطن سوداني انه تم قصفي منزله
لكن هنالك اكثر من مليون مواطن سوداني في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يحكي قصته كيف
نهب قوات الدعم السريع منزله وكيف سيطرت
على منزله الفريه التي تتحدث على ان هنالك
ما يتعلق باخوان مسلمين وغير اخوان مسلمين
الدعم السريع هو صنيعه الاخوان المسلمين
هم الذين اوجدوه للدفاع عن مصالحهم والان
بعد ان انتهى استنفذ اغراضه يريد ان يختطف
الدوله السودانيه ليس لمجموعه الشعب
السوداني ولكن لمجموعه محدده وحيده تحت
ستار اننا نحارب اخوان المسلمين دقيقه يا
صديقتي صديقه يا صديقتي ربنا يرضى عليك
الله يرضى عليك في تجميد لانسحاب بمعنى
اخر انه لا زالت قضيه الحل السلمي قائمه
او لا خلاص انتهينا باختصار
نعم القضيه قائمه اذا اثبتت قوات الدعم
السريع انها خرجت من المستشفيات مستشفى ام
درمان مستشفى الخرطومه الكبير
المستشفى شرق النيل مستشفى البان جديد
محطات المياه دار الهاتف حيث يسيطرون على
السياسي وعدم تهديد عوض شكرا جزيلا
السوداني الذي يتم الان ومن لندن عمران
عبد الله حسن عضو المكتب الاستشاري لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع شكرا جزيلا لك
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان الولايات
المتحده ملزمه بوقف اعمال الاستفزاز
بارسال السفن والطائرات طائرات الاستطلاع
الى حدود الصين قالت المتحدث الرسميه باسم
الوزاره ماونينج ان واشنطن تقوم منذ فتره
بعيده بارسال سفن وطائرات لاجراء
استطلاعات قرب الصين ما يهدد سياده الصين
الوطنيه ويهدد امنها معتبره ان مثل هذه
الاعمال الاستفزازيه هي السبب الجزري
للمشكلات المتعلقه بالسلامه في البحر
الخارجيه الصينيه اكدت ان الصين ستواصل
اتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه سيادتها
وامنها بحزم وهذه المشاهد مشاهدينا من
اعتراض مقاتله صينيه من طراز جي 16
استطلاع عن طائره استطلاع استراتيجيه
امريكيه فوق بحر الصين الجنوب نتابع
اعلن الادعاء العام الفيدراليه الالمانيه
اعتقاله سبعه اشخاص يشتبه بانتمائهم
لتنظيم داعش وجه الادعاء الالماني لهم
تهمه جمع اموال لصالح تنظيم داعش وارسالها
الى التنظيم في سوريا كما والمشاركه في
تحويلات ماليه تبلغ 65 الف يورو كان هدفها
الاساسي المساعده على هروب اعضاء من
التنظيم من مخيم الهول
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
رائده الفضاء ريان وعلي يصلانه هيوسن بعد
عوده سالمه الى الارض ويخضعان لحجر صحي
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه مررت لجنه
القواعد في مجلس النواب الامريكيه مشروع
قانون سقف الدين صوت سبعه اعضاء في اللجنه
لصالح المشروع وسته اعضاء ضده ستكون
الخطوه الثانيه التصويت على المشروع في
مجلس النواب وسط اعتراضات من التقدميين
والمحافظين ليرسل بعد ذلك اذا ما تمريره
يرسل الى مجلس الشيوخ يحشد قاده الكونغرس
المشرعين لتمرير المشروع قبل الخامس من
يونيو لتجنب تخلف الولايات المتحده عن
سداد ديونها دعونا
مشروع قانون سقف الدين يعبر اختباره الاول
بتمريره من لجنه القواعد في مجلس النواب
كخطوه اولى للتصويت عليه في المجلس قبل
ارساله الى مجلس الشيوخ
عدد من النواب الجمهوريين تعهدوا قبل
التصويت في اللجنه بفعل ما بوسعهم لايقافه
فيما هدد النائب تشيبراير رئيس المجلس ابن
مقارتي بازاحته من منصبه اذا تم تمريره
الاتفاق هذه المجموعه ستعارضه سنواصل
محاربته اليوم وغدا وبغض النظر عما يحدث
سيكون هناك حساب حول ما حدث ما لم نوقف
هذا القانون بحلول يوم غد بدوره دافع
مقرتي عن الاتفاق لست متاكدا مما يريده
الجميع لم نحصل على كل ما اردناه ولم يكن
بالامكان التحدث عن الميزانيه باكملها
خلال المحادثات وفي سعي لحج التاييد
لمشروع القانون اعتبرت مديره الميزانيه في
البيت الابيض واحدى كبار المفاوضين بشان
الصفقه شايلندا يونج ان الاتفاق مكسب
للشعب الامريكي
عندما نتحدث عن التخلف عن السداد فقد
انتصر الشعب الامريكي اليوم خاصه عندما
يصل المشروع الى مكتب الرئيس لاننا تجنبنا
ما كان يمكن ان يكون كارثيا تماما مسار
الاتفاق ليس سهلا في ظل غضب مشرعين من
اليمين الجمهوري وقلقي مشرعين من اليسار
الديمقراطي بسبب ما يرونه تنازلات قدمها
كل من الرئيس جو بايدن ورئيس المجلس كبل
المقارثي
بالتزامن مع ذلك يحجد قاده الحزبين في
الكونجرس الدعم للتشريع للتصويت عليه في
مجلس النواب اولا ثم مجلس الشيوخ حيث
يواجه ايضا معارضه جمهوريه
اعلن انه لن يصوت لصالح الاتفاق واقترح
بدلا من ذلك رفع سقف الدين ب500 مليار
دولار فقط والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات في
غضون اشهر قليله لوضع اصلاحات اضافيه
للانفاق
وكان السيناتور الجمهوري مايكلي هدد سابقا
بعرقله الصفقه لعدم تضمنها اصلاحات كبيره
في الانفاق والميزانيه حسب تعبيره حسين
الطاوض العربيه واشنطن
الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يكون اكبر تهديد
للبشريه هذا وفقا لرؤساء تنفيذيين لاكبر
الشركات التكنولوجيه الرائده في العالم
ففي بيان مشترك قال اكثر من 350 مسؤولا في
شركات كبرى من بينهم مبتكرات تشاد جي بي
تي قالوا ان مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي يجب
ان تعامل باولويه قصوى طبعا الى جانب
المخاطر المجتمعيه الاخرى كالوبئه والحرب
النوويه خاصه ان نماذج كتشات جي بي تي قد
تستخدم لنشر المعلومات الخاطئه وايضا
الجرائم الالكترونيه فضلا عن التسبب في
تعطيل الوظائف لدرجه ان تحل محل الانسان
او تدمر البشريه عن غير قصد المخاوف لم
تقتصر على ذلك اذ حذر اكاديميون اخرون من
تهديدات اكثر خطوره كتسريع الذكاء
الاصطناعي الى انهيار الحضاره وايضا الى
تاكل الديمقراطيه وحتى الى امكانيه
استخدامه من قبل البشر لتصميم اسلحه
بيولوجيه او وهو
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه على التطرق لهذا
الموضوع المهم جدا الذكاء الاصطناعي له
فوائد جدا كثيره في حياتنا لكن هناك بعض
المقاوف اللي ممكن يسببها الذكاء
الاصطناعي لكن خلونا نكون واقعيين اي شيء
جديد في هذا العالم قد يكون له محاسن وقد
يكون له مساوئ لذلك مع نشوء الذكاء
الاصطناعي او تواجد ذكاء اصطناعي ونموه
بشكل جدا كبير في السنوات القادمه يجب على
الدول ووضع معايير للاعتماد عليها
والاستفاده من مميزات الذكاء الاصطناعي
الذكاء الاصطناعي فوائد جدا كبيره راح
يختصر الوقت علينا بشكل جدا كبير يساعدنا
في اداء مهام جدا صعبه لكن يجب على الدول
الجلوس على طاوله ووضع معايير معينه حتى
نمنع بعض المشاكل الخاصه في هذا الموضوع
اليها منذ فتره خاصه في ظل الفراغ الانسان
القانوني او غيره والمتعلق بالذكاء
الاصطناعي ولكن عندما يخرج بيان مثل هذا
البيان بعيدا على
الاكاديميين ماذا يعني
يعني ان هناك مخاوف من عدم الالتفات الى
ذكاء الاصطناعي ومعاملته بشكل جدي بشكل
كبير لانه زي ما قعدنا نشوف حول العالم
ترى ما في دول كثيره قاعد تهتم في الذكاء
الاصطناعي وتعطيه اولويه في دول كثيره
حاليا ما يشكل اذا كان اصطناعي اي جزء من
اجتماعات هذه الدوله عكس مثلا عندنا احنا
في السعوديه حاليا في اهتمام بشكل جدا
كبير في هذا الموضوع واتوقع انه راح تكون
في مبادره تطلع من عندنا من السعوديه لوضع
معايير معينه للاستفاده من قدرات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لانه لازم يكون في دوله تقود
مثل هذا الموضوع حتى يبدا الكل يتجه له
ويبدا الكل يستفيد منه التقنيه لها محاسن
التقنيه لها مساوه لكن انا نمنع هذه
التقنيه بشكل كامل من حياتنا راح نخسر
كثير جدا وراح نكون متاخرين بشكل كبير في
حياتنا لديك معلومات عن خطوه قادمه من قبل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بدك بعض النقاط
ولا ما عندي معلومات دقيقه لكن اللي قاعد
يشوف اهتمام المملكه بشكل جدا كبير في
المؤتمرات الخاصه بالذكاء الاصطناعي واللي
قاعد يشوف المؤتمرات المتكرره والمبادرات
الكثيره من سدايا وغيرها من الجهات يعرف
ان اكيد راح يكون في شيء مستقبل السعوديه
قاعد تشتغل عليها انا ما عندي معلومه
دقائق ولكن هي قراءه للمشهد فقط حسب ما
قاعد نشوف من مبادرات مختلفه من الهيئه
الخاصه في السعوديه بس خلينا نقيم بما انه
عم نراقب ما الذي يحدث في اطار الضخ
المعلومات المتعلقه بالذكاء الاصطناعي اذا
ما وضعنا ذلك فيما يتعلق بالجانب الايجابي
او السلبي بالميزان اعلاميا اي جهه هي
الاكثر انتشارا اذا مصحه تعبير
الاصطناعي جدا كبيره راح تكون موجوده في
الطب راح تكون موجوده في حياتنا بشكل
هو يعني هو يتم التسليط عليها اعلاميا لكن
اي شيء سلبي انتشاره اكثر من الشيء
الايجابي لكن انا بقول لكم معلومه لو
منعنا ذكاء الاصطناعي راح نواجه معضله
كبيره في حياتنا خلونا نقول بشكل كبير
بشكل كبير دخول الذكاء الاصطناعي راح يغير
كثير ومنع الذكاء الاصطناعي من العمل في
حياتنا او التواجد في حياتنا وتطويره
والاستفاده من راح يشكل عقبه جدا كبيره في
الذكاء الاصطناعي ياخذ وظيفتك ووظيفتي
كمان انا
مو مو بشكل مباشر لكنه التقنيه يوم جت
الكمبيوتر الجوال وغيرها قالوا انه راح
يلغي وظائف لكن قاعد اشوف حاليا السوق
صحيح ان التقنيه التقنيه الغت وظائف لكن
اوجدت وظائف ما هي موجوده في السابق في
نقطه كمان مهمه كل الدراسات تشير ان
اطفالنا اليوم اكثر من 60% منهم راح
يشتغلون في وظائف احنا ما نعرفها فلذلك مش
عارفين اذا مؤهلين او غير مؤهلين لهذه
الوظائف عبد الله السبع المحرر التقني في
من الرياض شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
محمد وصلت الطائره التي تقل رائدي الفضاء
السعوديين على علي القرني وريان البرناوي
الى مدينه هيوسن بولايه تكساس الامريكيه
بعد انتهاء رحلتهما التاريخيه الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه يحمل رائده الفضاء 92 عينه
من التجارب العلميه التي تضمنتها المهمه
وقد اعلنت الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء نجاح
مهمه رائدي الفضاء السعوديين ريانه برناوي
وعلي القرني بهبوط المركبه الفضائيه التي
تقلهما وطاقم المهمه x2 بعد رحله علميه
متميزه في محطه الفضاء الدوليه تابعت
العربيه مراحل عوده مهمه الفضاء والتي
تحمل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علمتنها
وقد هنا رئيس التنفيذي لهيئه الفضاء
السعوديه دكتور محمد التميمي القياده
السعوديه والشعب على اكتمال المهمه
العلميه للمملكه في محطه الفضاء الدوليه
عقب نجاح هبوط المركبه
مركز العمليات الموحد لمتابعه رواد الفضاء
بالرياض وبعد وصول رواد الفضاء قبل قليل
للارض سالمين ولله الحمد وهنئ القياده
وهنئ مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين وسمو
سيدي ولي العهد والشعب السعودي بسلامته
رواد الفضاء وبارك لهم نجاح هذه الرحله
العلميه التاريخيه والتي ستسهم في رفعه
الوطن ومكانته في خدمه العلم والابتكار
وخدمه البشريه
[موسيقى]
الملف المائي هو من ابرز التحديات التي
تواجهها الحكومه العراقيه طبعا خلال موسم
الصيف ولاجل ذلك تقوم وزاره الموارد
الماليه او الماليه عذرا بعده اجراءات
لرفع التجاوزات عن مياه الغراف والفرات في
مسعن للقيام بخطه زراعيه وايضا توفير
المياه الصالحه للشرب نتابع
ارض هؤلاء المزارعين مهدده بالجفاف بفعل
التجاوزات للحصص المائيه على طولي نهر
الغراف والفرات في الناصريه جنوب العراق
وكلما توجهنا شرقا باتجاه الاهوار تزداد
المحنه ويصعب وصول الماء لهذه الاراضي ما
استدعى تقنين المياه من قبل الحكومه
العراقيه لتلافي الجفافه وتوفير المياه
الصالحه للشرب
المياه
مياه ماكو يعني عندك
اكثر تموت بها على الله
والدوله هسه قاعد تدور وانا تطور والحديث
وهذا يزيد معاناتنا المرشات وما قالت هاي
الحديثه
احنا مو ناجحه عندنا ارضنا طينيه
مراجعه ملف المياه داخليا ستشهد اجراءات
تتخذها الحكومه والتي تتمثل بمعاقبه
المخالفين وازاله البحيرات غير المجازه
وغلق منافذ مياه الصرف الصحي غير المعالجه
المسببه لاضرار بيئيه والزام الفلاحين
باستخدام نظام ري حديثه وفق توقيتات زمنيه
مقرره لجميع الوحدات الزراعيه عفوا هو
التحدي الاكبر اللي يواجه العراق عموما
ومحافظه ذي خصوصا هو تاثيرات التغير
المناخي والجفاف وهذا اللي اثر الى حدوث
حمائيه كبيره عن نبيها بالموسم الزراعي
السابق وكانت هناك بعض الحلول الانيه في
وقتها هو
القضاء على التجاوز على الحصص المائيه
بعد الاجراءات الداخليه تحشد الحكومه جهود
لاعاده تقييم الموقف المائي مع دول جوار
العراق لمواجهه موسم الصيف بخطه زراعيه
تضمن حصص مياه عادله لجميع المزارعين
وتتدارك توقف عمليات استصلاح الاراضي
الاعوام السابقه من الناصريه شاكر عواد
العربيه
الخامس انتهت مشاهدينا بهذا الخبر شكرا
للمتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات